Prince Bohemond the Third, King Louis the
Second of France, and the Byzantine Emperor
Michael The Second all had stutters so pronounced,
that they were each referred to as “The
Stammerer”.
So, even if you have a stutter, you could
be an emperor one day.
Hey there stuttering stallions, Jules here
for DNews.
A stutter is a type of speech disorder, when
your speech is involuntarily broken up by
repetitive sounds, or blocks where you can’t
quite say the sounds you want to.
More than 70 million people worldwide are
believed to be stutterers.
Some develop a stutter in childhood, and it
goes away.
Others can develop it later in life.
Boys get it more often than girls, and they’re
more likely to have it persist into adulthood
as well.
For a long time, it was believed that the
disorder was psychosomatic, meaning that it
wasn’t related to a physical cause, but
rather, a mental block, like stress..
Well it turns out, that’s not quite true.
A new study published in the medical journal
Human Brain Mapping looked at 62 people with
and without stutters, focusing on blood flow
in an area of the brain called “the Broca’s
area”, which is located in the frontal lobe.
They found that in people with stutters, there
was less blood flow in this region, and blood
flow in the brain is related to neural activity.
The more severe the stutter, the less blood
flow in the Broca.
So, what is so important about this part of
the brain that it causes stuttering?
Well, the Broca’s area is associated with
speech formation, alongside another part of
the brain called the Wernicke's area, in the
temporal lobe.
They are part of the “neural language loop”,
and are both necessary to produce clear and
concise speech.
The Wernicke’s area is the part where you
choose which words you want to say and in
which order.
It’s like a behind the scenes blueprint
or a storyboard for your speech.
This information is then fed into the Broca’s
area which produces those words out loud,
like a word factory.
For stutterers, their Wenicke’s area is
able to put together the sentences, while
the Broca’s area struggles to produce it.
The worst part of this is that in society,
people with stutters are often thought to
be dumber, simply because they can’t get
the words out, when in reality, they are no
less intelligent or eloquent than their non-stuttering
counterparts.
Another study, recently published in JAMA
Psychiatry looked at the brains of 94 stuttering
and non-stuttering children and adults.
They found that the baseline brain activity
— the way the neurons fired signals — was
different for stutterers in the regions of
the brain associated with the regulation of
speech production, attention, and emotion.
So, the root causes of stuttering could be
differences in brain circuits and blood flow.
But stress and anxiety can also take a toll,
making stuttering worse, because the parts
of your brain associated with attention and
language processing interact with the parts
of your brain that regulate emotion.
Stuttering is a complicated condition, without
any easy fixes.
Those who suffer from it may be able to curb
the tendency with the help of a speech therapist,
and for others, like children, it may go away
on its own.
But these new developments certainly help
point to the parts of the brain in question,
and may help scientists develop new solutions.
Have you noticed that when you record your
voice and hear it back, it always sounds awful?
Why do we hate the sound of our own voices?
You can find out why in this video right here.
And do you have any other language processing
questions?
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe for more
DNews everyday.